now we turn to the economy economy
dominated by rising inflation that just
won't quit the labor department says
consumer prices were eight and a half
percent higher in march compared to a
year ago that is the biggest jump in
more than 40 years led by a huge
increase in gas prices after the report
came out yesterday president biden went
to iowa to talk about efforts to drive
down prices at the pump he blamed those
higher gas prices on vladimir putin's
war on ukraine ed o'keefe is at the
white house ed good morning
vlad good to see you good morning you
know ronald reagan was in his first term
the last time inflation spiked this
quickly and americans sure are feeling
the economic strain and in blaming
vladimir putin president biden is now
using language that takes him further
than ever before
prices are up and americans are feeling
the pain
last month inflation jumped 8.5 percent
from 12 months earlier with energy costs
soaring 32 percent the high costs spread
to your kitchen too
coffee and eggs up 11 percent milk and
fruit also climbing and bringing home
the bacon
now costs 18 percent more
prices houston barbecue owner russell
rogel is feeling
everything goes up and down but it seems
like nothing's going down anymore
everything's just creeping up
higher costs for everything he buys and
sells are cutting into his profits
and he worries if his prices have to go
much higher customers won't come back
every time we raise prices they'll look
at the menu board and look down there
like whoa you went up and i'm like look
we we have to we don't have a choice
traveling in iowa on tuesday president
biden announced a cheaper mix of
gasoline known as e-15 will be available
through the summer months potentially
saving drivers as much as 10 cents a
gallon if their vehicle can use it and
while inflation's been rising for the
past year president biden continued to
blame russian president vladimir putin
and described his actions in ukraine for
the first time as genocide your family
budget your ability to fill up your tank
none of it should hinge on whether a
dictator declares war and commits
genocide a half a world away he later
clarified but didn't back down from his
comments we'll let the lawyers decide
internationally whether or not it
qualifies but it sure seems that way to
me
president biden also said that the
evidence of genocide is mounting and
that it's become clear and clear that
putin's just trying to wipe out the idea
of even being ukrainian
in response ukraine's president
volodamir zielinski praised the
president on twitter thanking him for
u.s support and calling his comments
quote
true words
of a true leader
tony
all right ed thank you very much